( intro music )
( muffled radio noises )
( swooshing sound )
( electronic hum )
( audience applause )
Dr. Kevin Hand: Thank you.
Thank you.
The question of whether or
not life exists beyond Earth
is one of humanity's
oldest, and I would argue,
most profound, and yet
unanswered, questions.
And the search for
life beyond Earth
is, in part, the story of
this lonely little planet
reaching out into
our solar system,
searching for possible
signs of life elsewhere.
We've been undertaking
this exploration
for just over 50 years now.
And through that
exploration we've just begun
to understand not only
which worlds out there
might be habitable,
but we've also begun
to better characterize
how our own planet
sets bounds on habitability
for life as we know it.
What I'd like to focus in
on are some of the worlds
that we've come to appreciate
just within the
past 10 to 20 years,
which on the surface
you might not expect
that these are habitable worlds,
but when you get to understand
what's going on inside,
it turns out that these worlds,
worlds like Europa,
Ganymede, Callisto,
Titan, Enceladus, and even
Neptune's curious moon Triton,
these are the worlds
that I like to refer to
as the ocean worlds
of our solar system.
Shown here of course at
the center is the Earth,
the ocean world that we
know and love the most.
But around the Earth I've
placed these icy worlds
of the outer solar system,
moons that are covered with ice,
yet beneath their icy shells,
we have very good
reason to believe that
vast potentially global
liquid water reservoirs exist.
These ocean worlds of
the outer solar system
are really transforming
our understanding
of what it means for
a world to be habitable.
In the early days of astronomy
and planetary science,
we had this sort of
"Goldilocks" scenario
for habitability.
The Venus, Earth, Mars system
defined what it meant for
a planet to be habitable.
In order for a world
to be habitable,
you had to have a nice
liquid water ocean
on the surface, in contact
with an atmosphere.
In order for that
condition to be satisfied,
your world needed to be
at just the right distance
from the parent star,
in our case, the Sun,
such that you had enough
energy from your parent star
to maintain that liquid
water ocean on the surface.
If you were Venus, you were
too close, and you got too hot.
If you were Mars, you
were too far away,
and you were too cold,
but if you were the
Earth's sun distance,
you were right at
that "Goldilocks"
sweet spot for habitability.
But these moons of the
outer solar system,
they're giving us a
sort of new Goldilocks.
At no place is this
better exemplified
than at the Jovian system,
where Io, shown here,
kind of takes the
place of Venus.
Io is the most volcanically
active body in the solar system.
What you're seeing in the inset,
in the upper part of Io there,
is a volcanic plume, a volcanic
eruption occurring on Io.
Io is more volcanically
active than the Earth.
There are likely volcanoes
erupting on Io right now.
Io is so volcanically active,
not because it's got
energy from the Sun.
It's so volcanically active
because of the
tidal tug and pull
that it experiences
as it orbits Jupiter,
which is some 318 times
as massive as the Earth.
In the Jovian system we
have this new Goldilocks,
where maintaining liquid
water is made possible
not by energy from
your parent star,
but instead it's
maintained largely by
the tidal tug and pull,
the mechanical energy
of these moons getting
flexed and stretched
as they orbit
Jupiter, and Saturn
and Neptune, Uranus, possibly.
In the Jovian system
we've got this new Goldilocks,
where Io is kind of like Venus.
In the early days, Io
may have had some water,
but now it's lost any
water that it once had.
It's too tidally active.
All the yellows, the reds,
the whites that you see,
that's all from these
volcanic eruptions.
Callisto, at the outer end,
though we think Callisto
does have an ocean,
Callisto's ocean is overlain
by a very thick ice shell.
That ice shell is also very old,
as evidenced by all
those little pock marks
on Callisto's surface.
Those are impact craters,
which to a planetary scientist,
indicates old age.
But in the middle we've
got Europa and Ganymede.
Europa in particular
we think may occupy
this new sweet spot of
the new Goldilocks zone,
where it's got just
the right amount
of tidal energy
dissipation to sustain
this liquid water ocean in
contact with a rocky seafloor
so that it can have
the elements and energy
needed for life, and it's
overlain by an ice shell
that is maybe a few to
as much as 10 or 15 or so
kilometers in thickness.
An ice shell that
maybe provides a window
into the subsurface ocean.
These ocean worlds of course,
from an astrobiology standpoint,
from a search-for-life-elsewhere
standpoint,
are so compelling because
if we've learned anything
about life on Earth, it's that
where you find the liquid water,
you generally find life.
From life
in extreme environments,
like hydrothermal vents,
hot springs in the rift
valleys, to Antarctica,
from life in extreme
environments,
to life of extreme lifestyles.
(audience laughter)
All life on Earth
depends on liquid water.
But I like to show this
image for another reason,
and that is that part
of the motivation,
part of what
underlines my passion
for exploring these worlds,
is that for all of the
diversity of life on Earth,
from the craziest of
microbe in the deep ocean,
to the most bizarre of
rock stars on the surface,
all life on Earth is connected
by the same tree of life.
All of life on
Earth as we know it
is connected by the
DNA, RNA, protein
and even ATP paradigm,
for how life works.
I want to know,
is there a different
biochemistry out there?
Is there a different way
to get the business of life
done?
Is there a place
in our solar system
where life has
originated independent
from life here on Earth?
Is there a second
origin out there?
I think these ocean worlds
of the outer solar system
are the prime places to go
and potentially
answer this question.
Europa, Enceladus, Titan,
all these moons are so fantastic
in the context of
trying to answer
this very primordial question.
So what's next?
I'll begin with a little
bit of my dream of dreams.
In my dream of dreams, we
send a highly capable lander,
to navigate to the
surface of Europa.
This would have to be
engineered such that
it could negotiate the canyons
and the cliffs of Europa,
find some spot on the surface
where there are no
icy rocks or boulders,
put down the lander safely,
and then deploy a melt probe.
This melt probe would
then have a heat source
that allows it to go
through this ice shell,
penetrating through the
many kilometers of ice,
eventually reaching
down to the ocean below.
After that it
deploys the nose cone,
and an autonomous
underwater vehicle
now navigates the ocean.
There's no joysticking
this from JPL,
( audience laughter )
so this little guy's
got to figure out its way
to the bottom of the ocean,
and in at least this
Hollywood version,
this is an excerpt from
"Aliens of the Deep,"
an IMAX film I
was involved with,
in this Hollywood version,
in the dream of dreams,
we make contact with these
charismatic macrofauna,
( audience laughter )
that ...
( laughs )
That's not real, sadly.
As I mentioned, this
is my dream of dreams.
Scaling back from that,
we are at the shores
of getting ready to
hopefully set sail
with new missions to
worlds like Europa,
sending missions
that will fly by,
look at the surface,
take pictures,
make chemical analyses,
and possibly even
use special radar
to see the interface
between the ice
shell and the ocean.
Then we'll send
landers and melt probes
and submersibles in the
years to come after that.
Part of what I get to do
at the Jet Propulsion Lab
and with NASA is kind of
build the earliest precursors,
the earliest robots
that we might someday
send to a world like Europa.
I'd like to share with you now
a piece that was put
together by Mark Thiessen
and others here at
National Geographic,
that shows you a
tiny step forward
in the technological
developments
that will someday lead toward
exploring Europa's ocean,
but today we're utilizing
to explore extreme
environments here on Earth.
( soft xylophone music )
Kevin Hand: The rover
that our team has built
is an early, early,
early precursor
of something that we may
someday fly to Europa.
The Buoyant Rover for
Under-Ice Exploration
is designed to float on
the underside of the ice,
and rove as if the underside
of the ice is the ground.
These ecosystems up in Alaska,
these lakes that
freeze over every year,
and freeze down,
they're just one example
of life in an
extreme environment,
that can help guide
us in assessing
whether or not a world like
Europa could harbor life.
All right.
We cut a hole in the ice,
put the rover
underneath the ice,
and then left it out
there to rove around.
We went back to a
nice, warm Quonset hut,
and our team was even
able to hand over
control to engineers
down in JPL.
(ambient music)
We think this truly
was the first time ever
that an underwater,
under-ice, untethered,
vehicle has been operated
through satellite link.
Our work has this
wonderful marriage
of advancing our understanding
of what's happening
on our own planet,
while simultaneously
feeding forward
into our exploration of
potentially habitable
worlds beyond Earth.
( rover scrapes across ice )
( audience applause )
Dr. Kevin Hand: Thank you.
I'll finish.
You've seen a lot
of great images
from our history of
solar system exploration,
but I'd like to close
with my favorite image
from the history of
solar system exploration.
It's an image carved
by the hand of Galileo.
An image carved
some 400 years ago.
Shown at center you see Jupiter,
and around Jupiter you
see four tiny little dots.
Initially when Galileo turned
his telescope to the sky
and observed these
four tiny little dots
around Jupiter, he named
them the Medician Stars,
the stars of Medici.
He did so because
the Medici family
was funding his research.
( audience laughter )
And Galileo was no idiot.
But as he charted the motion
of these little points of
light night after night,
he noticed that they moved.
He began to realize
that they in fact
were not stars,
but they're moons.
And if they were moons
going around Jupiter,
then that meant
that not everything
rotated around the Earth.
Through his careful charting
of Jupiter and its moons,
Galileo helped put the
final nail in the coffin
of Aristotelian
cosmology, this idea
that everything goes
around the Earth.
He really opened the doorway
to the Copernican revolution.
This idea, of course,
that we go around our sun,
our sun is a star, and
the stars that we see
might be suns to other worlds.
In the decades that
would follow Galileo,
we would come to appreciate that
the laws of physics apply
not just here on Earth,
but also to worlds
and wonders elsewhere.
In the decades after that
and the centuries after that,
with the development of new
telescopes and new tools,
things like spectroscopy,
we would come to appreciate
that the principles
of chemistry apply
not just here on Earth but also
to these worlds and
wonders elsewhere.
Then, with the advent
of the space age,
and our exploration
of worlds like Mercury
and Venus and Mars, we
would come to appreciate
that the principles
of geology also work
not just here but
on these worlds
and wonders beyond the Earth.
But when it comes to
the fundamental science
of biology we have
yet to make that leap.
We have yet to
understand whether or not
this bizarre phenomenon
that we call life
works beyond Earth.
We have every reason to
believe that it should.
Our study of life here on Earth
and our exploration of
these worlds elsewhere
indicate that we think
some of these worlds
should be habitable, based
on what we've learned
about life here,
but we have not yet
done that experiment.
Part of what excites me about
the time in which we live
is that for the first time
in the history of humanity,
for the first time since we've
looked up at the night sky
and asked that
primordial question
of "Is there life out there?"
we have the tools
and technology,
the scientific and
technological capability,
to do the experiment,
to see whether or not
biology works beyond our Earth,
to see whether or
not this phenomenon
we know and love called life
works on worlds and
wonders elsewhere.
So I hope that in
much the same way
that we can look at this image
and appreciate the revolution
that was catalyzed
by the observations
and the research that
Galileo and everyone did
some 400 years ago, I
hope that our descendants,
some 400 years from now,
will look back at our time,
and they will be able
to say, "It was then,
it was during that time,
that humanity did
the exploration,
developed the tools
and technology,
and made the discoveries
that brought our
universe to life."
Thank you.
( audience applause )
( outro music )
(orchestral music)